[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le mardi 21 janvier voici les
titres de cette édition la solidarité
des yvelinois face aux incendies qui
ravagent l'australie une association de
saint léger en yvelines a par exemple
confectionner poche sac et couvertures
pour les nombreux animaux blessés
reportage au sein d'un atelier couture
notre page consacrée aux élections
municipales à montigny le bretonneux il
souhaite prendre la suite du maire
sortant jean luc ourgaud laura merker
sera le candidat de la majorité
d'anciens directeurs de cabinet mènera
la liste montigny ensemble enfin la
compétition était un temps pressenti
pour être délocalisés l'open de france
de golf reste bien finalement à saint
quentin en yvelines
alors rendez vous se déroulera de
nouveau en été du 2 au 5 juillet analyse
de cette décision avec notre consultant
golf pierre chevallier
présentation aussi dans cette édition de
la plateforme vivre où c'est un service
destiné aux entreprises pour leurs
collaborateurs
un objectif trouver le logement idéal
mais direction saint léger en yvelines
pour débuter la section couture de
l'association culture et loisirs
solidaire est de l'australie les
bénévoles ont répondu à l'appel d'une
organisation suite au terrible incendie
survenu sur place pour aider aux soins
des animaux blessés ils ont fabriqué des
poches et des couvertures adapté plus
d'une cinquantaine de sacs a déjà pu
être envoyé le reportage de mathilde et
demi on a vu sur le site que ça leur
permet d'accrocher le sac et le bébé
kangourou il le met dedans et ça imite
la poche de sa de sa maman des petites
poches cousues de toutes pièces pour y
accueillir koala kangourou opossum qui
ont fui les feux de forêt en australie
suite à l'appel du collectif animal
rescue les élèves de marie pierre lors
d'un atelier couture à saint léger en
yvelines ont décidé de participer au
projet en créant ces faits qu on s'est
dit bon on fait notre part du colibri
une voile assez
oui c'est loin et l'australie oui on va
pas sauver la planète avec famille on
s'est dit on va faire ce qu'il faut pour
un autre mesure à la mesure de ce qu'on
peut faire et de petits groupes de
couture corner et bien participé aussi à
ça parce que nous avons besoin et c'est
important pour nous le groupe a déjà
envoyé une cinquantaine de poche via le
collectif qui redistribue les créations
dans les centres pour animaux que les
faits comme ça t'as pas de couture à
l'intérieur et puis c'est amovible comme
ça a eu là bas ils peuvent mieux
entretenir les les poches
madeleine est à sa quinzième création de
poche elle a délaissé tous ses projets
personnels pour s'occuper du confort des
animaux en détresse des premières sens
je pense qu'elles sont en australie
maintenant donc ces cds c'est
réconfortant de voir que des des petits
animaux qui sont blessés peuvent être au
chaud et puis bien protégé avec nos
poches
selon guo wei fund for nature les
incendies auraient déjà tué 1,25
milliard d'animaux
l'atelier couture de saint léger en
yvelines près par son dernier colis
avant de l'envoyer vers l'australie et
pour subvenir aux besoins des secours
sur place une cagnotte en ligne a été
lancé par une dizaine de sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines le but récolter
suffisamment pour partir aider sur place
l'actualité c'est aussi le début des
jeux trois c'est cette semaine les
épreuves de contrôle continu comptant
pour la note finale du nouveau
baccalauréat la tenue de ces 2,3 c a été
quelque peu perturbé dans plusieurs
établissements français est notamment
par des actions de professeurs à
guyancourt ce sont les élèves de
première du lycée de villa roi qui
doivent débuter les épreuves ce jeudi
qui ont mené une action ce matin devant
leur établissement
une petite centaine de jeunes présents
pour s'opposer à la réforme du bac il
dénonce un manque d'information de
préparation et demande donc un report
écouter ses propos au micro de marylène
iapichino les cours ne sont pas
banaliser on a pas d'heure prévu pour
réviser
ces contrôles communs sachant qu on est
en plein milieu du deuxième trimestre
donc on a aussi d'autres contrôlent pas
pour nos bulletins
on peut pas réviser on doit faire des
choix et c'est pas normal on n'est pas
censé faire des choix dans nos révisions
dans les matières qu'on doit réviser
toutes les matières sont importantes et
on est fatigué on a plus de temps pour
dormir on a plus de temps pour sortir et
c'est pas normal
sur les 3 c ils doivent avoir une
convocation au minimum 15 jours à
l'avancé et que là ils ont eu à peine
cinq jours à l'avancé donc du coup leur
tante préparation ils ont pas le temps
de
jean patent concrètement de préparer un
truc bien du coup ils sont pas du tout
d'accord sachant que même le proviseur
ne sait même pas concrètement comment ça
va se passer il ya un manque
d'organisation total est aujourd'hui
tout ce qu'on aimerait et tout ce qu'ils
aimeraient tous ses pouvoirs décaler les
autres enseignes de façon à ce que ça
soit mieux une réunion d'une réunion
pardon était prévue aujourd'hui entre
les délégués de classe et la direction
de l'établissement qui n'a pas souhaité
faire de déclaration pour le moment et
des actions similaires ont eu lieu ce
matin également devant le lycée
saint-exupéry de mantes-la-jolie et ce
matin au lycée françois guillon aux
mureaux un mode économie à présent avec
sept plateformes la plateforme vivre ou
qui a été développé par saint quentin en
yvelines et aussi à la start-up ya
tracts fruit de cette collaboration en
cette application qui est un service
destiné aux entreprises pour leurs
collaborateurs
l'objectif c'est de trouver le logement
idéal présentation au micro de nicolas
d'android beyrouth est une application
très simple d'utilisation qui permet aux
salariés de trouver le meilleur lieu
pour son logement
l'objectif est de rapprocher
de réduire les temps de transport et de
rapprocher l'habitant emploi c'est un
service qui est mis à la disposition des
entreprises qui est gratuit pour les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés qui
une participation financière pour les
autres
[Musique]
pour pouvoir définir ces critères on
commence par définir la composition du
foyer
donc par exemple deux adultes mais tant
que nous avons deux enfants
ensuite l'application permet en fonction
des ja de la composition de la famille
de faire une première sélection de
critères par exemple on peut être très
proche de certains services de santé
avoir des écoles à proximité puisque on
a mis des enfants en bas âge accéder
facilement à des commerces après c'est
des questions par rapport au lieu de
travail et le mode de transport et
ensuite quel logement est recherché
ensuite le logiciel agrège toutes les
bases de données et va vous faire des
propositions sur les lieux qui sont le
plus adapté en fonction des critères que
vous avez identifié
si vous cliquez sur une des communes qui
a été proposée vous pouvez explorer le
mieux avoir accès à tous les services
sur la commune en particulier sur tout
l'environnement et puis vous avez accès
à toutes les offres des agences
immobilières soin particulier à
particulier soit le bon coin donc toutes
les offres qui correspondent aux
critères demandés saint quentin en
yvelines où les voeux continue ce midi
jean michel fourgous présenté à les
siens aux forces de prévention et de
sécurité agissant sur le territoire un
moyen pour le président de
l'agglomération de remercier les 320
fonctionnaires de police et les 800
pompiers ainsi que les intervenants
sociaux l'occasion aussi de rappeler que
d'ici trois ans le commissariat futur
verra le jour sur le territoire et coûté
ses propos au micro de mélanie poker un
champ ticket en train d'être élaborée
donc et qu'il va concerner la
coordination du comice a dû lui en cours
de trappes édiles en cours pour bien sûr
améliorer la rapidité d'intervention
pour améliorer
la prévention pour améliorer la
coordination en entretien en étroit
partenariat est donc le dialogue avec
les élus est tout à fait permanent
fructueux vraiment travaillent de
concert pour assurer de la meilleure
manière possible la sécurité de toutes
les communes de la de la circonscription
d'elancourt
nous devons au quotidien travailler main
dans la main avec les forces de sécurité
pour assurer parfois notre propre
protection et à linverse lui aussi les
sécuriser
l'été veut également à la verrière en
fin de semaine dernière pour la
cérémonie et la mère nelly duthu a
souhaité mettre les talents de sa
commune à l'honneur après un discours
rappelant les conflits internationaux
les luttes sociales en france et
l'urgence climatique et 17 vers hyérois
ont été mises en lumière pour leur
action ils sont sportifs artistes ou
membres associatifs tous remerciés par
la commune pour leur énergie
marylène iapichino pour les interviews
un bon tiers des gens d'ici sont là
depuis très longtemps
c'est eux qui façonnent cette ville
depuis longtemps et puis là de
génération en génération
ce qui donne une histoire et une
spécificité
à la verrière et
et il faut là il faut la saluer cette
spécificité et je vous assure ça c'est
pas la moitié de ce qu'il ya comme comme
talent sur la verrière et a énormément
de gens qui sont en attente de pouvoir
libérer leur les énergies libéré c'est
ça que je veux c'est participé à cette
libération
on reparle veut à la verrière mais tout
à l'heure dans notre page dédiée aux
élections municipales
une bonne nouvelle pour le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'open de
france saura bien organisés dans les
yvelines du 2 au 5 juillet
l'officialisation l'officialisation je
vais y arriver est tombée en fin de
semaine dernière le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
bien une nouvelle fois l'open de france
de golf l'événement qui s'est tenu pour
la précédente édition en octobre revient
également pour une session estivale
c'est du 2 au 5 juillet sur le site
localisé à guyancourt
on en parle avec pierre chevalier
bonsoir consultant golf sur tv 78 alors
c'est le tour européen
promoteur du tournoi qui a confirmé
l'information à la fédération française
de golf on précise que la compétition
avait été un temps pressenti pour être
déménagés dans le var est ce que c'est
une bonne nouvelle comment vous vous
l'accueillez oui ça lui c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle pour le golf français le
golf en france et dans les yvelines en
particulier c'était le serpent mère qui
qui s'était articulé depuis
finalement depuis la fin de la ryder cup
2018 en septembre 2018 au coach national
avec cette ce doute qui planait et qui
avait été annoncé lors de l'édition 2010
9 en octobre dernier de l'open de france
qui avait été délocalisé déjà qu'ils
avaient qui avait été déclassé en termes
de calendrier international et qui
s'était retrouvé au coeur de au coeur de
l'automne au golf national et il y avait
ce doute qui plane et le tour européen
avait avait émis
l'idée que cela puisse comme comme par
exemple open l'open britannique vit open
est délocalisée chaque année c'est à
dire et après changer de lieu par
rapport par rapport au golf national et
le un des deux lieux qui avait été
retenu au sud était le complexe de
terre'blanche au même titre que le golf
du médoc près de bordeaux mais pourquoi
il fallait qu'il reste à saint quentin
en yvelines on précise que le
rendez-vous est présent sur place depuis
2002 voilà depuis depuis 2002 il a été
utile et rendre dans l'histoire l'open
de france mais depuis 2002 il est fixé
au golf national
il ya plusieurs raisons qui font que
c'est à la fois une bonne nouvelle est
que et que ce cette compétition puisse
rester au golf national d'abord l'open
de france de golf national ça sonne
assez bien deuxièmement c'est un vrai
stadium de golf ça n'est pas à dire que
le domaine de terre blanche n'est pas
non plus fait pour le spectacle golfique
mais leurs cinquante ans de vie n'est la
ryder cup et la conception même du
terrain et du golf du parcours du golf
national de l'albatros a été fait avec
des buts des buts naturels qui font
autant de gradins naturels sur sur
l'ensemble du parcours et qui ont
d'ailleurs qui a d'ailleurs donné
énormément d'avantagés le point de
visibilité pour le pour les spectateurs
et puis il faut pas oublier aussi que
c'est un c'est un investissement qui
c'est long un investissement qui c'est
qui a démarré en 2010 quand on a su que
la france organiserait le la ryder cup
en l'occurrence est donc le énormément
de d'efforts et financiers ont été faits
par la fédération française de golf par
les licenciés de golf en france pour
pouvoir mettre le parcours à niveau
désormais c'est un vrai parcours de
championnat qui est plébiscité par tous
les joueurs
faut il faut écouter notamment les
joueurs français qu'il qui ont une
affection particulière pour ce parcours
en parler comme victor dubuisson qui
disait que notamment avec cette amen
corner du trou numéro 15 autres numéro
c'était un reggae à un vrai parcours de
championnat dans un état absolument
impeccable
quel que soit désormais quelle que soit
la saison grâce aux investissements qui
ont été faits qui ont été faits dabbagh
et je disais tout à l'heure ça revient
l'été et en face en face sur un tournoi
majeur du pga tour qui sera programmé un
tournoi qui se déroulera aux états unis
avec une dotation largement supérieur on
ne sera autour des 10 millions d'euros
alors que l'open de france c'est plus
flou alentours des 2 millions d'euros
ça c'est une faiblesse c'est une
faiblesse de la lord récurrente de
calendrier c'est à dire qu'effectivement
on sera en face d'un tour du world golf
championship au sein de news
international vite ationale c'est à dire
que grosso modo tous les meilleurs
joueurs de la planète seront seront aux
états unis on peut on ne peut que le
déplorer pour le plateau le plateau et
l'affluence qu'il peut y avoir
intrinsèque grâce au plateau que peut
attirer le coach national
on devrait avoir les meilleurs joueurs
français une partie des meilleurs
joueurs européens
mais les américains et les tous
meilleurs robinson seront aux états unis
merci à pierre chevalier pour cette
analyse consultant golf de tv 78 l'open
de golf qui reste bien donc à saint
quentin en yvelines et c'est une info tv
60,18 la compétition devrait rester sur
le territoire jusqu'au moins à l'édition
2023 connaissez-vous les origines du
festival de cannes le célèbre événement
de cinéma est devait se tenir pour la
première fois en septembre 1939 volonté
à l'époque du ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean zay pour contrer la
mostra de venise sous domination
fasciste le festival ne se déroulera
finalement pas en raison de l'entrée
dans la seconde guerre mondiale une
exposition vous le voyez l'image revient
sur cette épopée elle est proposée à la
bibliothèque universitaire de l'ue vs
cul à cul en cours et jusqu'au 30
janvier documents d'archivés images de
l'époque sont visibles les propos sont
que les eaux collectées par patrick
jacques de dixmude et rémi lefebvre
c'est jean zay qui à l'intérieur du
cabinet était ministre
de l'éducation nationale mais on change
également de tout ce qu'on appelle dès
aujourd'hui la culture c'est lui qui a
vraiment fait pencher la balance pour
que le festival ait lieu c'est un anti
fasciste convaincu et il a été comme
d'autres choqué par l'évolution du
festival de venise quelques mois
auparavant qui devient un festival
fasciste contrôler à la fois par
mussolini par hitler et donc il faut
réagir mais la france peut pas réagir
seule et elle est aidée par hollywood
c'est très intéressant c'est ce que des
travaux récents ont montré un colloque
qui a eu lieu il ya quelques mois c'est
que sans l'aide de lits ou
d'effectivement ce festival de cannes
était impossible mais j'en sais tués
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale ne
verra même pas le festival de cannes la
première édition se tiendra sur la
croisette en 1946 elle les élections
municipales à présent à la verrière le
candidat divers gauche en île blé a
présenté ses voeux lors d'une réunion
publique c'était en fin de semaine
dernière il porte la liste intitulée et
vivre et décider ensemble lors de ce
rendez-vous l'actuel premier adjoint de
la commune a détaillé les premières
mesures de son programme les détails de
nicolas nombreuses ouvertures des
centres de loisirs jusqu'à 19h création
d'une équipe de médiateurs pour la
tranquillité publique en fin de journée
nocturne de l'accueil mairie jusqu'à 20
heures
les premières propositions concrètes de
la liste vivre et décider ensemble porté
par jean yves blé un programme global
pour la ville de la verrière
on veut relancer une attractivité pour
notre ville notre ville se meurt
les gens var ne veut pas y rester on le
voit en discute avec les gens on est à
l'affût de des besoins du bien-être de
nos habitants que ce soit dans le
quartier du bois des temps que ce soit
au village ou à orly parc et pour le
futur quartier gare de cannes
en plus des projets d'aménagement d'orly
parquet des bécanes il y à la rénovation
du quartier du bois de l'étang
jean-yves les portes un programme de
démolition partielle la destruction
d'environ 180 logements soit un bâtiment
revoir les appartements aussi puisque
une réhabilitation c'est ça passe aussi
par les a les habitants à l'intérieur
avec une priorité de ceux qui restent et
puis avec une charte de relogement qui
sera signée avec les habitants où on
garantit qu'ils seront relogés là où il
le souhaite
on peut penser par exemple à réunir les
deux écoles qui aujourd'hui vous avez
une école maternelle dans un quoi et
puis un groupe scolaire de l'autre autre
point du programme pour les habitants
sans complémentaire la mairie pourrait
négocier des prix attractifs auprès des
mutuelles une mesure au coeur des
échanges de la réunion sur la santé
prévue mercredi 22 janvier à 19 heures
au scarabée à montigny le bretonneux le
maire sortant divers droite jean luc
bourgault ne se représentera pas en mars
prochain il avait pour rappel succéder à
michel laugier devenu sénateur des
yvelines en 2017 et pour conduire la
liste de la majorité y nîmes antenne
laurent amércaine bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous conduirez la liste montigny
ensemble une première candidature
candidature pour vous vous avez été
directeur de cabinet sur les mandats des
maires de nicolas bour michel laugier et
jean-luc hugo pourquoi sortir de l'ombre
en quelque sorte et vous lancer dans
cette démarche
eh bien je pense que au fil de toutes
ces années où j'ai appris à connaître la
ville à gérer des dossiers très
importants et a rencontré aussi beaucoup
d'habitants
lorsque l'on cumule cette expérience il
ya un moment dans la vie de chacun ou
franchi une étape et on se sent prêt
pour passer à autre chose et il ce
rendez vous du 15 mars arrive pour moi
comme le moment en parfaite adéquation
avec ça c'est le moment pour moi d'y
aller je pense
une expérience qui remonte à 2001 vous
avez presque 20 ans du coup d'expérience
à ce poste que vous êtes il a pris ce
poste
et à quoi ça vous ça va vous servir dans
cette aspiration à devenir mère
justement le poste de directeur de
cabinet j'ai pu m'en rendre compte en
discutant avec des habitants encore tout
récemment tout le monde ne sait pas
forcément très bien ce que c'est c'est
le premier collaborateur du maire c'est
donc celui qui est en charge de mettre
en musique en application la politique
avec l'administration
c'est celui aussi qui est le relais avec
les partenaires institutionnels
l'agglomération la préfecture et bien
sûr qui est aussi en lien avec les
habitants les associations
donc ça permet à la fois d'avoir une
vision précise de la ville des enjeux
qui peuvent se poser pour la ville de
connaître les dossiers structurants qui
la concerne et en même temps d'acquérir
une connaissance à la fois des quartiers
et des personnes pour pouvoir mener à
bien ensuite une fonction d'élu local
dans le cadre de ma fonction j'ai
toujours été sur le terrain j'ai
toujours dès le départ
en soirée sur les week-ends voulu
m'impliquer dans la vie associative dans
la vie des quartiers
parce que je crois que la fonction de
d'élu local c'est vraiment une fonction
on doit d'abord être au contact des
habitants contact direct c'est aussi la
façon de faire des mères que j'ai
accompagné
et c'est aussi la façon de faire de
l'équipe qui a choisi de me faire
confiance pour la conduire aux
prochaines élections justement cette
équipe est ce que elle est uniquement
l'héritière de la majorité sortante vous
avez souhaité tout de même apporté
quelques nouveaux visages au sein de
cette évidemment il faut renouveler une
équipe c'est très important
il faut pouvoir mais les expériences
parce que la gestion d'une ville est de
plus en plus complexes les dossiers sont
de plus en plus difficile à monter et
donc il faut des gens qui est une
certaine expérience
mais en même temps il ya un vrai besoin
d'avoir un regard neuf qui viennent
s'ajouter à cela
donc j'ai souhaité renouveler à 50%
l'équipe à peu près de façon à pouvoir
mixer ces deux éléments
une liste que vous revendiquez sans
étiquette même si vous êtes plutôt de
sensibilité centriste alors c'est
absolument moi je suis centriste je n'ai
jamais été encarté dans aucun parti
la liste que je conduis est une liste
d'ouverture
elle a toujours été historiquement une
liste dans laquelle on comptait une
bonne proportion que l'on qualifie de
centre-droit mais elle a toujours été
ouverte et elle a toujours été elle a
toujours accueilli des gens d'autres
sensibilités et surtout aussi beaucoup
de gens qui ne sont pas encartés comme
moi mais qui avait envie de faire des
choses pour leur vie les scuds éventuel
soutien par exemple du parti des
républicains de l'udf je sais qui est
aussi des discussions avec la république
en marche est ce que vous les
accepteriez ses soutiens effectivement
je n'ai pas sollicité mois de soutien
auprès d'aucun parti par contre certains
partis m'ont fait l'honneur de me de
m'apporter leur soutien
gg ainsi le soutien de l'ue dei par
exemple le soutien des républicains
je n'ai pas sollicité le soutien de la
république en marche non plus
effectivement j'ai pu avoir des
discussions avec eux mais encore une
fois ce qui m'intéresse avant tout c'est
de prendre avec moi des personnes qui
ont envie de se mobiliser pour leur
ville alors pour avec cette équipe il y
aura il y aura trois priorités ans pour
votre programme tout d'abord la
transition écologique qui est un point
que l'on voit revenir souvent dans de
nombreux programmes c'est un point sur
lequel il faut compter pour pour ces
élections ne peut pas faire sans
aujourd'hui non je crois que c'est
devenu totalement incontournable c'est
pas une question de parti ça n'est pas
une question d'idéologie
on est bien conscient qu'aujourd'hui on
arrive à un moment où il faut que les
modes de vie changent et donc là-dessus
effectivement je les ai évoqué lors de
la réunion de lancement
je souhaite vraiment que nous puissions
à un travail sur ce sujet très important
parce que il faut que la ville puisse
accompagner ces changements tout ne peut
pas se faire au niveau d'une ville mais
on doit être un acteur incontournable de
de cela et je crois qu'on a la capacité
de le faire on a tout d'abord la
possibilité d'agir dans chacune de nos
politiques publiques en veillant à ce
que pour chacune d'entre elles on est
bien la notion de transition écologique
qui soit intégrée dans les critères de
choix et ensuite on a aussi par le biais
de l'exemplarité par le biais de la
sensibilisation par le biais du faire
ensemble des choses qu'une ville s'est
portée avec ses habitants le moyen de
d'accompagner cette transition
écologique et de faire tout notre
possible contribuer à notre échelle en
tout cas pour que les choses puissent
évoluer favorablement sur ce sujet il ya
un autre thème sur lequel les habitants
sont de plus en plus attachés c'est la
sécurité puisque vous prévoyez sur sur
ce thème sur la sécurité
alors évidemment montigny n'est pas la
ville qui présente le plus de grands de
problèmes de sécurité aujourd'hui pour
autant
montigny ne vit pas dans une bulle et on
a des problèmes d'incivilité et parfois
de délinquance comme partout et ce que
l'on peut constater c'est que quels que
soient les gouvernements la réponse est
insuffisante et l'expérience que j'ai au
fil de ses 19 années c'est que
finalement c'est le maire qui est le
lien entre l'état et les citoyens qui
doit être en première ligne sur ce sujet
et qui doit mettre sa connaissance à la
fois des partenaires mais aussi des
quartiers et des personnes pour pouvoir
mettre en place et en mettre en oeuvre
les bons dispositif pour pouvoir agir
sur les problèmes d'insécurité et donc
c'est vraiment pour moi quelque chose de
très important et qui doit se faire
aussi en contact avec les habitants qui
sont les premiers concernés ont fait
déjà ce travail aujourd'hui on travaille
beaucoup et des amicales de locataires
par exemple qui sont pour moi des
partenaires incontournables car ce sont
eux qui ont la connaissance de ce qui se
passe dans les quartiers et c'est à
leurs côtés qu'on souhaite mener cette
politique non ça c'était pour le 2e
pilier le troisième pilier c'est la
réhabilitation du secteur dit de l'hyper
centre autour de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines la ville et
l'agglomération ont lancé une
concertation pour la rénovation de ce
quartier qui a été achevé on le rappelle
en 1987 et qui est jugé aujourd'hui
vieillissant pourquoi c'est un pour un
projet important pour la ville et
comment finalement rendre ce quartier
plus attractif alors vous l'avez dit
effectivement c'est un quartier qui a
beaucoup vieilli
l'icaunais beaucoup de beaucoup
d'usagers il concentre et ce aussi
énormément de choses et à l'ape à
l'époque de sa conception
favorisent-elles minérales ont favorisé
l'automobile aussi
aujourd'hui les gens aspirent à plus de
végétal à plus de l'espace piétonnier et
aussi à ce que l'on puisse créer des
lieux de convivialité
donc il ya nécessité de travailler sur
tous ces sujets et sur ces sujets là
nous avons souhaité lancer une
concertation avec la communauté
d'agglomération en associant les
habitants
parce que c'est un quartier économique
un quartier étudiant très important mais
c'est aussi un quartier d'habitation
et donc il faut que les habitants soient
concernés par le sujet pourquoi aussi
nous souhaitons temps faire évoluer ce
quartier c'est parce que on a pu voir
ces dernières années qu'en faisant de
gros efforts sur la gare en faisant des
efforts sur les espaces publics qui
jouxte la gare
on a vu immédiatement dernier
des opérations importantes pouvoir se
faire comme la transformation de
l'immeuble internationale celle de
l'immeuble de la poste
donc on comprend bien que quand la
collectivité investit sur l'espace
public et réalise des espaces qualitatif
ça entraîne derrière des mutations
importantes y compris dans le privé
aujourd'hui il ya un enjeu très fort sur
le centre commercial on le sait tous et
je pense que notre rôle à nous villes et
intercommunalités
c'est de faire ce qu'il faut au niveau
des espaces publics à la fois pour le
rendre le quartier plus agréable pour
les habitants mais en même temps plus
accueillant pour les gens qui viennent
travailler là et incité également les
privés à pouvoir faire évoluer aussi
leur patrimoine
il nous reste quelques secondes vos
prochains rendez vous de campagne à
lausanne ont tracté sur les différentes
places de la ville le premier week-end
de février
il y aura également une réunion publique
à nouveau à la salle jacques brel
le 26 février où j'espère que nous
accueillons autant de monde que la
semaine dernière
et puis ensuite nous continuerons de
tracter jusqu'à là jusqu'à l'élection
merci laurent marquet hier tête de liste
de montigny ensemble représentant de la
majorité sortante et face à vous pour ce
scrutin au moins deux autres listes
montini solidarité conduite par l'ancien
conseiller municipal d'opposition pierre
déjean et la liste m conduite par un
binôme le conseiller municipal
d'opposition actuelle un vivien gasc et
également avec caroline ce chaos
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]